every now and again in eSports a player
emerges in a game to become the hero
[Applause]
to carry his team onward to victory and
send the crowd to their feet out qtwave
backs it up hey claps right into the
GRANDMONT even more rarely the hero
emerges in front of their hometown crowd
with the cheers of the faithful ringing
in their ears these moments are elevated
by the crowd and their love of the local
boy you can thank you know a father
taking otherwise amazing plays and
bringing them to iconic status
therefore it's right that the moment we
look at today a highlight that caused
the player to go from local favorites to
legend which is one game happened in the
Philippines
this is DJ's black holes from the Manila
major hey are you kidding me from the
low ground when valve announced its
third major would be in Southeast Asia
it was only fitting that Manila the
capital of the Philippines would receive
the honor of hosting few places on earth
are as dedicated and passionate about
eSports as the Philippines and dota 2 is
among the foremost of their loves it's a
fantastic country very vibrant very
colorful and the best crowns on planet
Earth
better believe it at live events the
crowd is either loud or outright
deafening and not a decibel lower
[Applause]
and so when one of the sons of the
Philippines pulled off the play of the
tournament and became the hero his team
needed you better believe the crowd and
everyone watching would never forget it
in the club a collision in front of the
SDA crowd more than a few systematic
groove on the top stage
this Filipino crowd have a Quidditch
game or it may just be one but one is
all hate it's time for the main event on
the first day the Filipino crowd had to
watch as mineski sports 5 was eliminated
from the tournament by a lion throw of a
dagger down goes the throw and a lion
Boogaard
save for five Mineski eliminated here at
the manila major in front of a hometown
crowd a brutal way to go out but it does
set the stage thankfully there was one
se a representative remaining fanatic
while the fanatic Rosser was mainly
Malaysian there was still one Filipino
left on which the crowd could pin their
hopes Jardel chico DJ man post e with
mineski out of the picture the pressure
was on for fnatic to deliver
unfortunately fnatic was set to take on
the ever threatening LGD gaming who had
topped their group and we're looking to
knock the final se a team into the
perilous waters of the lower bracket not
entirely sure what else it is up to or
what they did I just know that phonetic
probably stronger than ever right now
and what I need to do is play their
style draft solid lineup and just be
themselves you know LGD took a confident
game won in just over half an hour
everybody go down without assuming
protect focus of something to blackball
positive in once almost fanatic will
lose three not as they've been 5x we're
going to find a fortune that is GG comes
out LGD will see feasible one pretty
gifted best gun but fnatic struck back
in Game two
to draw the series even our rabbit
shuffling shall I do entirely now we can
stack them on top of that will fall
instantly doesn't have my language well
another rabbit and it gets it out of
three this time maybe say folks that
psab from coming through and he will
fall then 406 and aggressive I stood up
CJ
fnatic will take Game two LGD came into
the deciding game three hard-and-fast
taking the fight rate to fnatic and
pushing the tempo early a lot of damage
they have may be coming in three prior
to do the job and they will def will get
your first one we're getting going
Boulder they get to set up and kick into
the Sun from step nicely gun the he'll
come through the brief fire as well Nick
get a pick up again on three four three
two second s this game don't even think
I'm even more going bowling on the net
missed again with there she is fence
bomb in this title house roar will come
out they have the magnetized they get
off the balance as well to Ohio game
right look down The Exorcism will go
from Russia doing a decent amount of
damage said rather divorce will come
through no offense but as it look to
take control of the game and solidify
their grip with a dive in the mid lane
PJ had something to say about that he
had the kinetic oops there's a black all
under three separate blows everyone are
going to get to down bring dead moose to
get the double kill
TJ are you kidding me from the low
ground DJ God - probably the chosen
plane and he hits the black hole of
inside that's exactly what fanatic
seeded
despite fanatics best efforts LGD
continue to push forward with their mid
game power spike turning up the heat on
the fan favorites queued up by the exes
and they get off to the Meccans well the
shadow wave and now mushi has to go to
Oregon and show it instead we've got no
managed using rabbit though he did
totally get sports away and actually say
Clemson back do they have to damage
for showing time he's got rabbits just
want to use it he will but it catches no
one knew she's still getting chewed down
by aggressive he gets the right to the
opals they'd finally get the tail on the
goofy fnatic and LGD he takes is getting
caught in the fact that this is again
guy however through some fancy maneuvers
out of mid one and great base hold by
the whole team fnatic wouldn't say done
get the racks now
LGD the rest of them have to back they
have to buy back on aggressive as well
shall wait having to head out woman and
PL will doppelgänger to the low ground
with 50 HP can they catch him at I'm
open we'll try to keep you around us
right now he'll take it anytime we want
TP from mid wine what a play from the
young star maybe is actually gonna go
toe-to-toe with big one and blues and
aggressive is now going toe-to-toe with
Ohio but E is getting to through by the
exit they have to rolling Boulder away
they will at least lose this firstly
with fanatics late game carries coming
online and LGD seeking the death blow it
was once again time for DJ to be the
hero it was black pattern atop price of
it slow take it up the steps
professor stand up maybe he's getting
through surface I'm in one big oaf or or
tillers do Dylan's three they fly back
in the guy you've got another rabbit a
snow by that gun maybe what an initiate
from d-day and they'll find another one
they get him my men want me to double
the crowd is going absolutely freaking
nuts god I licked my head down like wall
like what eject black hole insane you
couldn't have planned it any better
and the crowd roared with delight
fanatic took the win on the back of DJ's
brilliant played very local a fanatic it
seemed like destiny that not only which
fanatic put on a sensational performance
DJ would play the game of his delight in
front of his hometown fans
[Applause]
Hasenpfeffer stand up maybe introduce
everyone
pick it up the wrong colors 2003
they will try to say
[Applause]
[Music]
while fanatic wouldn't win another game
for the rest of a tournament swept out
by newbie and then to liquid in the
grand scheme of things that doesn't
really matter why because everyone loves
a hero and on that day in Manila the
Philippines had theirs and his name was
DJ
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]